hello and welcome to this video and
playing bako trying the Bangkok amber
let's go for something for something
active and you place this line now this
is a very sharp line which is as i
remember in incorrect but it is very
very young it's very very brutal and and
not I don't know it I know that g5 is a
possible reply but I looked at this line
for white million years ago and I don't
really remember I remember that
ultimately I I found out that it is not
good but I don't remember why hmm 25
maybe mm-hmm you hang a bishop a sexy
and very weird very weird stuff okay
be three chick mp3 checking everyone or
what is the deal check okay I'm going to
play it ask questions later hmm yeah
Queen a 2 is not working yet or is it
and almost almost it's not threatening
to take this in he isn't but what am I
doing here would you like to clarify the
situation somehow cannot move the night
Jeff this is this is immediately getting
killed maybe you're threatening every
year that that's possible I mean maybe
let's do something weird the idea is
Queen a to
ok a four
and now I could actually go back to our
six and detective five what did what an
extremely strange position not that i'm
not sure that i actually threatened to
take it to be honest i just read
develops now 95
not so much about the PO I just want to
text something we prob therefore okay so
we should be seven I guess on I mean I
can take here Bishop takes Queen B 5
checked a group takes a one these kind
of things but I don't think it works
okay if I take f 4 by the way Queen
takes on a eight my night is hanging
unfortunately
I could take here though and now kick
f4f the rook protected so Queen takes
now is not working yet maybe I can go
with this it's one of the weirdest
position that I remember having okay
got no time position is probably pretty
good how to believe that and I don't see
em checkmating me that's what I'm trying
to say and the beep one was strong okay
with now I have again sometime I can go
clean before for example or Quincy 33 23
here activating the cool didn't have
this move on the radar okay
I wanted to put the Queen and c3 to make
g3 more difficult but that time I didn't
work that did not work neither 794 maybe
Oh
check talk about weird stuff I can
probably just move the wow check check
check I managed to get to an ending here
Wow 35 seconds I does he have some some
checkmate here maybe you can construct
your checkmate but ok the bishop is
covering a one
so long as suspicion is coming a one I
think it should be kind of okay
95 probably should give form no that is
going to check them yeah 10 seconds
buddy this is this is your your whole
point Jim check maybe I felt bad thing
checkmate yeah that's a shame I mean
after Queen d2 of course I'm okay which
I'm with the Queen's traded it was a
very Becky position yeah okay this is a
line as I said it's it's it's not good
for white but it's it's something that
you have to know and I don't know it I
studied this like 20 years ago for white
and there's a reason why nobody plays it
the engine gives Knight f6 with the
clear maybe this is the move I don't
know I know that g5 is right this is
what I remember but maybe maybe here we
are already this is already strange
let's say a check yeah King da de da
funkee move and my king position is very
very bad so and probably yeah here
bishop d2 was winning and I denied d5
didn't really work okay when he went
here here okay I should go Queen takes a
cheater says Chad couldn't really I
didn't really think it worked this is ok
according to the engine hmm really have
a nite nite rook
yeah it's tough to argue with this
engine okay I didn't didn't think about
this yeah I know why my king position is
just it yeah long-term issue check yeah
Bishop d3 now it's stopped which gives
plus 100 so but that should be a maid oh
my god yeah instead you played this
weird move yeah fortville ub5 check
probably yeah I don't really have a
movie I think check check check this
kind of thing check check yeah yeah
after the Queen trade I'm clearly okay
rupee six yeah okay would be six it's a
perpetual but I wanted to win now of
course this is probably too risky yeah
yeah why this is why this veneno the 95
he has a force made funny enough might
be six is so strong check check Luke b3
was mating with ok this also does now
okay that can happen how you play a
sharp opening opponent plays a dicey
line that you have to know to reviewed
and then you get into this trouble they
can happen okay well thanks for watching